so these cops
caught lying and with their abusive
behavior
remained on the street
we own this city
[Music]
the story of we own the city is about
the gun trace task force which was
probably one of the most corrupt squads
in policing history in america
the actual police work of protecting a
community of solving crimes had
collapsed that was already critiqued in
the wire
the next moment in the history of
baltimore is that officers were actually
just robbing people what you got in here
eleven thousand wow that's the equity
from when i refinanced my house the
equity mines
a lot of thought went into how do we do
this in the most careful way when did
you first start doing robberies it was
my armed robbery
every story in this series was based on
some real life true event you can feel
that on set it gives a different level
of attention to detail a different level
of authenticity to see it on screen is
going to be triggering for a lot of
people getting the whole world there's
always one watch the trade-off is it has
to be shown because it's the only way
we'll ever get this reform that
everybody dreams about
shooting this in baltimore you can't ask
for anything more we have to tell the
story here with these folks for these
folks and by these folks
[Applause]
[Music]
it happened in baltimore and we're here
walking in their shoes now
meeting people that they affected why
you put me up anyway
why did we pull him over realize he's
obscured
don't look obscure to me
it was quite emotional to be hearing the
stories from passes by telling us what
it felt like and what hasn't changed and
what needs to change police yourself my
father worked for the department of
investigation in new york so i had a lot
of respect for a lot of the practices
but sustained for some of the
institutional things and so i was sort
of always in the middle
those nuances hopefully make their way
into the storytelling process because
these are human beings put in real life
situations and what would you do if you
were put in that situation i don't know
man you don't know man it's yours you
earned it you have all these different
points of view and every point of view
is given some validity it's really easy
to just make this guy the bad guy and
these guys are the good guys and on some
level that is what's happening but
there's just more nuance to it if you
want to do this job then you're going to
get complaints for doing this job
this store is so relevant and will
remain relevant until something actually
happens to change that
we're trying to explore the tension
between trying to keep the city safe and
doing it in a constitutional way i think
we're still trying to figure that out
it's not a partisan issue if policing is
fair then it's good for all of us
you